[Musique]
on pensait qu'il allait la Sommer mais
il s'en sort pour le moment
et cavaliers
quelque chose d'un maximum
je vais commencer à te menacer des tours
des 7 pour te pour te claquer une car
attention
ça a été raté par Wesley il a raté un
truc
gagnant après cavalier C7
depuis tout requin il fait une partie
catastrophique Wesley
et qu'on va plus revoir côté Wesley
allez c'est légalisation pour Maxime et
c'est B4 pour essayer de gagner la casse
pour le cavalier quoi et s'activer
rectified il l'a vu je pense ouais c'est
après parce qu'il a fait un petit
sourire comme Maxime l'a joué et ça fait
ça fait deux ans alors l'ordi donne un
seul coup pour gagner
et c'est tour G2
bluff ici
qu'il avait trouvé en fait
ça maximie les trouve cela et abandons
instantané sur le comprend aussi et
c'est la pause déjà bah qui ça a l'air
ah ouais ça a l'air particulier ces
conditions de jeu mais après je crois
qu'il est sur souris sur un ordi
portable j'ai l'impression j'ai juste
qu'on a l'habitude de le voir jouer sur
cette immense sucre écran d'habitude de
Wesley t'as pas la rêve de des
conditions de
qualité dans le bois à jouer sur un
immense écran sur lequel l'échiquier est
minuscule
en fait les chéquiers doit prendre un
huitième de la taille de l'écran ou quoi
et les Ch'tis absolument minuscule il y
a pas de tours
de l'escalier escalier
moment
il y a quelqu'un qui lui a demandé de se
décaler
c'est terrible en fait quelqu'un qui
parle dans la vie
il a dû déplacer son ordi
mais tu peux dire que
alors apparemment il est très mécontent
du coup il a fait une tête bizarre comme
s'il avait raté quelque chose bon il a
joué le coup main
apparemment un mec a raison en fait il
tourne l'ordi toi pardon il y a un gars
qui le fait chier dans la bibliothèque
j'arrive pas complètement à voir mais
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a quelqu'un
qui a un truc qui le gène nettement ok
ça explique un peu les les
déconcentrations en fait il y a des
Français qui carient dans la
bibliothèque en fait ouais c'est ça il y
a tous les Français qui sont à la
bibliothèque de minée Sota le faire
chier en fait
si domine bon si la perd pas c'est déjà
bien aussi
[Musique]
peut-être
c'est chaud
il prend des quatre il a pas pris mais
il a gagné
c'est quoi cette pause
il a deux dames Maxime ça fait 6 2
mais c'est terrible il y a maintenant il
y a l'ampoule qui s'allume et qui
s'éteint chez Wesley
et oui il y a plus de lumière chez
Wesley c'est revenu il en peut plus en
fait il est écoeuré ok il a raison de
réfléchir quand même Maxime une petite
peau de banane peut se poser un peu
n'importe où dans ce genre de poste
il faut pas le laisser revenir pour rien
voilà voilà ça a été trop vite trop trop
n'importe quoi
le set fou G6 c'est vrai que ça a pas
l'air facile d'éviter mat ça va être
sûrement tout rêve cette forcée mais il
faut prendre FC renona
mais là ça a été trop vite et trop j'ai
rien compris mais moi non plus j'ai pas
eu le temps
non non je suis quand même un peu mieux
au foot mais le temps passé enfin sur la
technique je suis pas très bon quoi il y
a des atouts c'est pas que de la
technique quoi au tennis c'est faut
quand même toucher un peu la raquette
quoi en fait tu peux courir tu peux
défendre enfin voilà tu es défenseur en
fait tu tapes dans le dos tu mets des
coups de genou dans le coccyx j'ai joué
au foot pendant 3-4 ans
tu as fait combien de blessés
en fait c'est à cause de toi qu'ils ont
introduit les six changements
il va décaler sa caméra sur une chaîne
il a pas encore regardé en fait Maxime
juste il le voit pas mais
Maxime il est tout contenté
il a pas encore regardé les filles quoi
mais là il se fait bibliothèque
peut-être allez Maxime il faut juste
clique là faut jouer sur la bibliothèque
ah bah ça tombe ouais ça va tomber je
pense que ça tombe quoi
ah il tombe pas Wesley pour le moment
voilà il est complètement gagnant
maintenant et le pion qui va arriver en
B5 et c'était pas loin attention quand
même essaye de complètement gagnant pour
le faire gagner pour les noirs
C8 et tu prends la colonne une erreur et
voilà c'est une dame
du coup tu nous dis c'est toi le
spécialiste de belette tu dis c'est
Maxime qui a l'avantage quoi tu dis
spécialiste
c'est pas moi on veut ton expertise
les multiples peut-être que tu nous
lâcheras en quelques-uns de tes
meilleurs secrets en tout cas je joue
mieux en belette que de notre premier
match
arrêtez quasiment maintenant joueur
redoutable et redouté
on n'a pas envie de croiser Baky 83 en
belette certains ont même arrêté de
jouer en belette après t'avoir croisé ta
route tu m'avais mis 6-0 la première
fois c'est de là que c'est parti en fait
ça t'avait fait très mal quand même le 6
0 tu tiens connais pas
tu t'es dit il est un peu nul il a un
peu con je vais quand même le battre
mais ouais c'est ouais
ça avait rendu Maxime très heureux
d'ailleurs ce match raison il a fait des
bons coups quand même faut pas il faut
pas minimiser le Wesley il a pas
forcément encore la tête dedans
foncer parce qu'il a ça a pas l'air
d'être un mauvais joueur de Bullet et tu
vois heureusement qu'il a quand même les
deux points d'écart un Maxime à égalité
sur un peu moins serein on est quand
même assez William il va très vite ce
pion et c'est tourné trois tours 3 il va
beaucoup trop vite allez Maxime qui peut
peut-être encore la sauver
mais il y a peut-être un dame en réalité
et tous les pions sont coupés le pion B
peut plus avancer
et le roi qui va venir se charger du
pion G
sans trop de difficultés
et Maxime qui abandonne attention Baki
il faudrait pas avoir un frisson ici
à l'ordinateur de la égal quand même
quasiment maintenant ouais c'est qui a
raté une grosse chance parce que les
pions sont sur blanc c'est pas la bonne
couleur il peut même la gagner au
maximum en fait un cavalier des cinq
échecs
c'est hyper tendu
il y a le Punto qui part
Maxime qui en envoie des deux côtés
oh il menaçait dans ma chambre
voilà la partie qui est absolument
infernale elle vaut très très cher
celle-là
ça peut faire tilt l'un ou l'autre ok
oui après le titre est plus cher pour
100 vu que il y aurait
de nouveau de points d'écart
la partie qui est bouillante
là c'est le niveau de jeu et et
hallucinant
comment est-ce qu'ils n'ont toujours
rien gaffé les deux c'est encore sur un
fil je crois que ça tient il a eu la il
a eu du bol à Maxime
et ça va tenir le pouvoir réussir à
revenir
ça apparemment oui c'est quoi cette
position c'est incroyable
ouais c'est trop
là le bol est incroyable
un salaire complètement perdant et ça
tient c'est fou il va quand même mettre
le cavalier en D8 avec
incroyable mais je pense que c'est au
tempo sur les couleurs et tout je pense
que c'est ce que tu peux pas
triangulaire avec un cavalier
pas banal cette position
il s'en sort peut-être trois
allez maintenant c'est toi
qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué
bah qui c'est terrible il a raté d'un
pro 4 il faut le faire
quel niveau de jeu des deux côtés
incroyable et c'est égalité Baki
attention elle leur dit donne fous prend
le 4 allez let's go ça part let's go ça
part de là
enfin une gaffe et en plus si la paye
cher parce qu'il avait une tellement
bonne position allez il faut il faut
réussir à la terminer mais elle a l'air
assez facile à t'en reprend j'ai trop il
va encore qu'il prend le 4 [ __ ]
qu'est-ce qu'il est malin ça doit aller
pour maximiser il doit y avoir encore du
Tour G4 tout simplement ouais mais elle
est pas gagné encore et qui prend des 6
il peut décalé la tour
elle est pas encore gagnée évidemment
ah mais ça ça fait du bien
elle a pas l'air très dur quand même
bâti
il a l'air elle a l'air assez facile et
cavaliers
ils sont autant brouillés et ça fait
quoi ça fait deux pions de plus pour
Maxime pas complètement fini encore
qui va arriver de l'autre côté il
s'embrouille et Wesley
maintenant qui est un peu dans
l'obligation de gagner mais qui ne va
pas y arriver
en B2 ça va être trouvé par Maxime c'est
terrible pour Wesley et Kylie B2 à
chaque fois qu'il a été obligé il a bien
joué Maxime il est juste plus fort dans
ses cadence et c'est
c'est pas forcément que le chrono est
mort donc il a raison de continuer à
jouer terminé quatre points d'écart
ouais match quand même relativement
serré un Baki heureusement que que
Maxime a pris large au début et on vous
dit à demain pour la suite merci à tous
ciao ciao
[Musique]